hello I seen fun friends here's your
quick intro thanks to everyone who came
to the Hollywood improv lab to see the
live taping of I seem fun I had a great
time
and we're gonna do another one in
September tickets are already on sale
just go to my website Jen Kirkman com
click on tour dates and in the show I
mentioned my upcoming gigs in Scottsdale
Arizona helium comedy club Buffalo in
New York State and Portland Oregon
helium both comedy club is for Buffalo
I won't I won't be back to Buffalo or
Arizona in 2017 so don't miss me if you
live anywhere near there drive out it's
gonna be worth it and don't forget that
in Portland um one of those gigs is an I
seem fun live taping so again all this
is on my website Jen Kirkman not
conflict or dates the most important is
October 1st Bowery Ballroom it is my
comedy special taping again tickets at
the door are a thing you can unless it
sells out which it probably will but I'm
sure they'll always be a little bit at
the door because people flake and I
think they hold a certain amount aside
to sell at the door but it's going to be
a nightmare because there's going to be
so many people and camera crews and all
this and we really need to start on time
and here's the thing we need to know how
many people are coming for so many
technical aspects and I don't want to
have to go hire audience but if enough
people don't buy tickets by a certain
point we've got to do that cheesy thing
where we send out notices to an audience
service I don't think we're gonna have
to do that cuz it's New York City and
that's my biggest fan base that's why I
picked it inks I love the city but it's
$12 I kept it $12 so that people could
buy in advance without stressing too
much I know people are very very broken
$12 can sometimes be a lot of money but
please
try to get them in advance and they are
available now the 7:00 p.m. and 10:00
p.m. show Saturday October 1st and there
on my website Jen Kirkman comm click
tour dates and there's no drink minimum
at a place like that so it's just $12
maybe there's a little service fears and
they actually don't know but just like
that tickets and yeah that would be so
helpful if I can see a sellout at least
on one of the shows by September 5th
I'll be really happy I'll be ecstatic
and relaxed if when I go under my
anesthesia the morning of August 31st I
find out that the Early Show has sold
out I will I really will
okay that's it thank you to everyone
thank you to producer Mike made a live
appearance tonight I mean no one saw him
but he was there he would oh he was
there thank you to everyone who helps me
with this podcast everyone at all things
comedy I am part of the all things
comedy Network go to their website all
things comedy comm you always ask me one
of their podcasts you listen to Jen a
lot of them are on that network so go
check it out find ones for yourself that
appeal to you
it is a quality comedy podcast network
run by comedians and you are supporting
comedy on so many levels by supporting
the podcasts of this particular podcast
network and the ice cream fun email
address I seem fun at gmail.com send me
a letter it can be an interesting story
or fact that you want to share with the
world it can be about any of the topics
we talked about an I seem fun it can be
follow-ups to things you've written in
about it can be advice you have for
other I seem funders on previous
episodes and even though their lives may
have been handled by now I bet it could
help other people you can talk about
things you find fun that other people
don't or
things you don't find fun that you don't
get what the [ __ ] other people like
about it and also don't forget the
community of I seem fun on Facebook is
where I go since I'm not on Twitter on
my own anymore there is still the
Twitter account I seem fun podcast where
you will see pictures and all kinds of
tweets and fun things and retweeting
what are a sorry I can't speak I can't
speak but anyway but Facebook
facebook.com slash I seem fun is where
we all go together the new episode
descriptions are posted every week and
you can comment on things about the
episode and Instagram is just me at Jen
Kirkman
there is no I seem fun Instagram account
let's keep it all under my roof and god
what the f oh geez
I sold some merchandise the show tonight
we've got Keep Calm and seem fun posters
posters of me given the finger
we've got rich [ __ ] mugs mugs that say
[ __ ] the haters beautiful full-color I
seem fun mugs with the logo the picture
of me yelling into the phone all those
and a bunch of t-shirts so many
different kinds of t-shirts you can't
believe it all on my website Jen Kirkman
comm slash merch or just go to the
merchandise page okay here's this week's
episode
hello I seem fun friends and friends
have I seen fun prints I am Jen Kirkman
missus episode I [ __ ] I forgot to look
producer Mike's here do you know what
episode this would be one forty
something good one
thank you I've got to announce it at the
beginning I'm gonna go on my iTunes
right now do I subscribe I do this is oh
I stopped putting the numbers about five
weeks ago oh they don't show up on
iTunes mmm well I don't know where else
I put them Facebook hang on we're gonna
look we don't need to do this but that
now how many people do not listen to
this podcast I'm not asking because I
want to shame you I need to know for
myself so I can give an explanation of
something or not so clap if you have
never heard this before it's too many
why would you come why okay this is
episode 145 yes why would you come to
something that you don't know what it is
and it's you're not gonna like it like
it's not there's no gasps it's I talk
off the top of my head it's not my
standup
you're not gonna like it but you will be
wrong you'll be wrong not to like it
because it's like a whole thing that
we've cultivated over years together and
um but people that like it are really
great people that don't I'm sure you'll
love it this guy brought my hot water
kettle onstage I know Dax said no
photography but he didn't know he was
dealing with me I would love you to take
my picture and tweet it and say this is
so funny I love I seem fun
please though I'm having I turned 42 on
Sunday and thank you yes and I'm having
a I don't know if this happens anyone
else the week before your birthday you
feel so ugly I don't know what it is
like do you know how like right when you
just let you know in your hair is making
you crazy and you hate it and then you
decide to get it cut and then that day
it's so amazing and you almost feel bad
like a kid believe I'm gonna cut you
like in it were it so the week before my
birthday I always felt gross like my
skin is ten different colors it feels
dull I just feel gross I thought I tried
to put on a night and a blue pants suit
to wear for you with gold shoes I felt
bloated it looks
then I just everything feels and so I
I'm wearing my what I call like it's
it's like a fun you see it in like on
Pinterest like Street fashion you know
like that like like off-duty model but
you have to be so skinny to wear
something like that that it looks like
oh she's just trying to cover it up but
this looks like oh she might film that
out we don't know so um anyway so I
thought that'd be a fun outfit then when
I stood on stage and I'm like oh god so
okay here we're gonna talk about we're
gonna I'm gonna read an article to you
we haven't listened or emails I'm gonna
have one I had one list okay so I
recorded a whole episode last week that
wasn't a line I accidentally deleted it
I don't know what happened it was on my
iPad it was uploading I left the house
that came back it was no longer on the
app that I recorded on I was like I
can't deal with this so I didn't and I
didn't do an episode but I answered an
entire listener email that I went deep
this person was like how do I meet men
and I think I said you need to meet
yourself and I told her not to date for
a year and it was but I don't remember
her name but I think she'll know if
she's listening I think it was a woman
it was a woman and she had never dated
anyone before and she was in her early
20s it hasn't been going well and she's
like where do I meet people and I was
like I don't [ __ ] know where you meet
people because I would just meet comics
on my whole life or I would meet how
would I meet people everyone I'm
thinking am i how the [ __ ] do I meet him
I don't know how I meet people but I've
never done like an app or anything like
that but that's the kind of life I lead
us excitement but if but maybe if you
live in the town and there's a lot of
people there I don't know how people but
I would have a couple people answer her
question because I don't think mine was
helpful it I just got a vibe reading it
that this person was maybe thinking our
relationship would fix certain things
and I was like I think if they had
hobbies they this is I am this is when I
know I'm a hundred I was telling her if
you have hobbies do those and the right
person will show up in the Hobby
situation what do you do I said do you
go to the I said this is it go to the
library or go to a coffee shop I don't
know what I just feel like if you had a
magic via like 10 hobbies a week
remember that episode The Brady Bunch
were Jan kept signing up for things and
she was like dude does anyone remember
that episode of was it Marsha
so either one of the girls it was like
the first week of school and she wanted
to be popular so she
for every club and she was standing at
the wall with her pencil she was like
booster club this and then signing no
one here wants Brady mention okay do you
know what that episode no oh you do okay
um I don't know what happened if she
became popular I think the message was
you don't have to do all that [ __ ] but I
was saying the opposite to this person
do a lot of activities and you'll just
enjoy yourself and don't get to know
yourself better and that energy will
attract someone I don't know how or
maybe not I don't know but or you'll
meet someone in your group but you're
not gonna go she doesn't like to go to
bars and stuff like that so I just felt
like this person might have been a
little down on themselves and I felt
like if you take the pressure off and
decide to make it a thing that you're
not going to date for a year then you'll
always win at that you can't get that
wrong you can't go I'm not gonna do this
and then there's no one around so you're
not going to break that so it's great I
think this whole episode the the through
line will be relationships because I
went to two weddings in the past two
months and I have an article here from
somewhere about single people being
discriminated against okay so I now
again it's not the point of where I was
it's just the band and everyone who
involved in this wedding is lovely I
went to wedding this weekend I would say
more about five hundred people were
invited that's not a joke and I didn't
get a plus-one now it's fine
but it's one of those things where I
think only married people got plus ones
because it was just so many [ __ ]
people then again it was local let me
give an example my good friend got
married in Cabo in July and it was only
60 people that's between her and her
husband they're both 40 in almost 40
they've lived a long life with many
friends from many different industries
family members people that invited them
to things they could only buy 60 people
that's so that was a small wedding that
was very expensive for them and then
you're you know Cabos on an island but
you're on a small thing together and you
don't want riffraff right you don't want
your loser friend who's like I just met
em two weeks ago and then you can't
bring that guy there like
our friend that got married in Cabo we
have a mutual friend who at my friend's
my friend who got married in Cabo let's
call her Jane Jane and I have a mutual
friend let's call her Jane number two
Jane number two at Jane's house warming
party [ __ ] her boyfriend in the
bathroom of my friend's house which is
fine like where there was just more like
why like they just met there was it was
a new love they were excited and it's
like so that's what Jane is Jane to the
friend yeah that's what Jane 2 brings to
the table well drama a little spice so
you got why you don't want to give Jane
1 just a plus-one Willie [ __ ] nilly
right and so I get that for that and so
my friend said to me I know you're in a
relationship but well when she first
first planned the wedding she I wasn't
in one she goes if you get in one by the
time my wedding comes you can have a
plus-one don't tell anyone and I go I
don't think I want one I think she
invited our other mutual male friend
let's call him bill he's like I don't
know I'm saying different names but it's
not a unhappy story but you know Bill's
like our mutual male best friend it's
like Three's Company everyone's always
been platonic and I wanted to it was my
friend Chris I wanted to hang out with
Chris and so Chris and I were each
other's dates even though he had a
girlfriend and I'm in relationship to
but it was like we don't need to bother
bringing these people into the thing
like we want to sit and talk and it's
just so much easier of the two of us are
just each other's date and then we know
everyone and it was actually one of
those weddings you spent time with the
bride and groom and so it was perfect
and nobody there was a was a rift to the
raft now this other wedding I went to
last weekend I don't know who all 500 of
these people were but I bet having been
married myself just because someone is
married doesn't mean that's the best
idea for like in other words
okay so I'm married so I'm considered
safe to invite to a wedding because you
can't tell someone who's married their
date has to stay home but when I was
married I would have rather had that
guys stay home than the current
relationship I mean I don't want him to
say if that makes it so and no one was
like hey here's your invite also if
you're in a relationship please tell
them to stay home like they just when I
got the invite I don't think they knew
oh she's back in this relationship she
was in before so that's fine it was not
like my best friend was getting married
then again it seemed like only people
who married got plus one so we raised
the question what do you do in that
situation
what should society do should there be
new rules about it because I got there
and I'm alone and I there's nothing
wrong okay
let's put it this way if I was single
that's great I would come with a
different attitude fabulous and single
hi everybody like you put your Samantha
on you know and you're just like Moo
who's over there you know when you do
that but I had to wade through a bunch
of acquaintances I hadn't seen since I
got back together with my ex going maybe
you'll meet a guy at the wedding which
is not ever what about [ __ ] do anyway
and so I'm already angry I'm gonna talk
about in therapy I felt not seen for who
I am
and it's like just get over it you're
out of wedding people making small talk
I don't want them to and so they would
say that and I go oh I'm in a
relationship I got back together with my
partner and they go oh well it's still
fun to flirt oh really why don't you
leave your [ __ ] husband at home and
and [ __ ] it up at the table I noticed I
noticed it meant something to you to
bring your best friend and lover to this
wedding ceremony it's fun to flirt and
by the way not everything is about a
[ __ ] date man or woman like how about
I might just have fun at the wedding
because you're all my friends and
there's music and there's love in the
air and we're all in great outfits but
the people that greet you at the door
like that make it [ __ ] seem like it
has to be about men and women and then
you get all wrapped up like it's not
about that but it is but not but it's
okay and so then there was that
conversation I'd have 10 times and then
I started feeling bad like oh my god I'm
not close enough with anyone that they
know and
think about my life like you guys know
more right and then I start spiraling oh
my god if we hadn't broke up two years
ago and took this two year hiatus then
we would be together and it would be an
automatic plus-one and all of our mutual
friends were there and he doesn't know
the groom and bride well enough to have
gone on his own and I was like I just
like it was a Saturday night I hadn't
hung out with my guy in a long time not
a long time but a few days I wanted to
spend a Saturday night with my person
and so I'm not trying to be a baby but
I'm not home a lot and so I was like
this is kind of annoying so I feel like
in that way you've got it at a [ __ ]
plus one you're asking people to go
dateless on a Saturday night into a
situation where they might not know
anyone or they might only know couples
or they're being asked to leave their
partner at home on their one night free
together like why do you get to do that
is what I'm wondering and so again if
it's not an intimate wedding like
there's only ten people and I don't even
know if the groom can come then you're
like totally I won't bring it when
there's so many people that you're like
is that a waiter is that a person not
the people aren't waiter you know what
I'm saying so I was just a little
confused now here is the point about
that so then I had to hang out a lot of
couples I know which is fine but you
could tell that they were trying to have
some couple time and then I was like I
was when first we got there it was like
a reception for two hours just drinks so
that's great so you can move around but
again I had to every time I left a
couple I had to go to a new one and do
the same thing maybe you made someone
here like at my age at 42 at a wedding
that's full of professionals in my
industry and friends of mine who am I
gonna hook up with first of all it's all
couples so Who am I hooking up with but
let's just say there was someone single
there unless you deliberately sat them
next to me and tried to set me up with
them how am I gonna find them like I'm
gonna go [ __ ] someone I met at my
friend's wedding like a like a trash
person you know like because again it's
in LA so where we gonna go like at
midnight I'm gonna drive someone home to
my place like not doing that it's
exhausting and so
I just don't even it's you know what it
is is when people that have been
marriages for so long forget what it was
like to either be single or arrive
somewhere without your partner they
don't even know what that is anymore
so they say stupid [ __ ] like maybe
you'll meet someone because they're like
trying to act like I know what it's like
to be alone for one second cuz I never
can be
and so now I'm turning it on them like
they don't know how to be alone like me
if I had a plus-one I would it but if
you like if you suddenly have more money
than you ever had and you forget and
you're like why can't people just buy a
Mercedes though I don't get just buy one
and so I so I was very confused about
this and I started to feel bad because
everyone that I didn't get a chance to
run around and say I'm not unhappy
you know I'd be fine if I were single
but I am and a healthy happy thing but
it's fine but I'm okay
so there was no like some people were
seated with couples some single people
were seeing with couples I just happened
to not get seated with really anyone I
knew except one person
a friend of mine that I ran into at the
end of the night and she and I were both
like and so but i sat with some people I
didn't know and she I want to say I
would say there's some of the more
busted people at the wedding if that
makes sense physically and just
emotionally and there was definitely a
singles table but it wasn't like the
fabulous fun ones it was like if we
don't invite these people there's gonna
be perhaps an incident like like we'll
never hear the end of it or they'll
reveal something to the media so I sat
down and I won't say whose side this
person was on the bride or the groom but
it was a woman and I again god bless all
his creatures and however he made them
look oh by the way and another night I
couldn't sleep last night we will get
back to the busted woman I woke up at I
went to bed at 10:30 or 11:00 I woke up
at 11:30 and my body was like we're done
we're done sleeping now we're gonna
think about death and so I just kept
thinking about
like God we're gonna die I'm gonna die
have no idea how hope I don't know I go
I wonder if everything I do can bring me
comfort until I die like being in a
relationship or doing comedy or sing my
family or having drinks with friends and
I went through each scenario and I went
no no no no no and I couldn't find the
comfort by picturing it and I was like
this this feeling I had I was like I
don't think this is ever leaving I'm in
utter panic I'll probably have to start
doing like really hard drugs I was like
oh and then I felt better in the morning
but then I started thinking I know
everything about God and all this and
then I thought did I make this up you
tell me if I made this up or not I think
I did but perhaps it's been said before
if it isn't I made up a [ __ ]
brilliant thing I think this was at 3:30
a.m. when I still have fun I took a
melatonin the kindness was to knock you
out in 15 minutes it never not has done
that just this one night and then I took
a klonopin after that because that
didn't melatonin didn't work then the
klonopin didn't work and then I was like
well I'll just see what I think while
I'm laying here and I thought because I
was getting into a discussion of my
Instagram based on this crazy person's
bumper stickers on their cars it was
like I love Jesus
Trump rules Hilary's a [ __ ] and I was
like it was made no sense and a lot of
people were writing like making fun of
religion that wasn't when I was trying
to do I was trying to say this car is in
Hollywood and my family a family member
recently called me a Hollywood liberal
even though I hate it here so much and I
think it's the least liberal place if
you've ever pitched a television show
these [ __ ] morons and so it couldn't
be less liberal like I don't know where
the Liberals are maybe there's some
Democrats that's on a liberal and I'm a
Democrat and a liberal but you know what
I'm saying
so I put that the whole point of that
post was to say there's all kinds of
people in Hollywood not just liberals
and I learned to be one in Massachusetts
not even Hollywood like I would ever
learn anything from any of the [ __ ]
idiots that we have to deal with you
right so whole conversation about God on
my Instagram I'm trying to keep it pause
it pause II I have no opinion on God I
don't have any idea if there is
seem crazy to me seems also crazy to me
that there is it oh so um don't care I
think it's great thing is beautiful so I
thought in bed so somebody was like oh
yeah the usual argument disease war
famine like Oh God really great God
there and I was like that's not it I'm
gonna get into it and so in the middle
of the night I thought disease war
poverty and famine are not proof that
God doesn't exist only proof that we do
get it it's proof that humans exist we
did that perhaps so did anyone ever say
that before no you're like it's not that
great that's why no one said it listen
I'm telling you that's [ __ ] good you
don't think if I said that on Oprah
she'd do like one of her signature like
to the audience like we got we got one
here it's like and I'd be on like her
Elizabeth Gilbert would start being like
magic time she's right up there having
on our podcast I mean that is a good and
not but maybe you don't get it what I'm
trying to say is that there's a
traditional God he or she made the world
and went you do it making wars happen or
not happen we're doing we're in charge
now and we take the strength of a higher
being to get through all that [ __ ] that
we made so again if anyone asks you Jen
Kirkman said
poverty disease warned famine are not
proof that God doesn't exist only proof
that we do how about humans do that's
better so I'm at the way and I sit down
now I'd gone to the dry bar in Pasadena
oh [ __ ] it doesn't matter if it you know
where the wedding was um I went to the
dry bar before the wedding and I got my
hair blown out in a very they called the
Manhattan sleek and smooth and I had it
blown out very straight and sleek now
men I feel like why can't you blow dryer
on here a blowout is a whole thing it's
a whole it's you can't do it yourself
you need two hands and they make it all
sleek and it's magic and it's great you
can't do it yourself so I do it and
they're like big plans tonight
oh god this going to a wedding everyone
that's going to that wedding has come in
here and then they told me all these
details and people weren't supposed to
talk about the wedding
so I was like these people are snatching
so I get there and I get to my table
which again I had plenty of time
socializing before I just sit down and
you could totally get up from your table
so it wasn't like I've stuck there and
it was just one girl again
it's know what I'm saying about God's
creatures I don't listen I never felt
more disgusting than I do right now and
this week I just don't feel cute so when
I say someone looks all busted up and 20
years older than she is I don't mean
that to be mean or like I'm better I
just mean that person should not
dispense with the hair advice that's
something
so this woman who could have been 35 or
55 an old 35 a young an old 55 as one
she had what you would call black roots
white blonde hair I know I've got two
different color hair I hope it looks
delivered hers was like haven't been to
the hairdresser in four months things
have been you know it was either that or
pay off my weed dealers so I did you
know I do an at-home thing I don't think
you can tell though I think it's pretty
good so and her hair was very dry I
sympathize with do you know that your
hair gets older like the other day I
looked in the mirror and one of my
brunette pieces was all wiry like a grey
hairs but I knew it wasn't a piece that
was dyed and I was like why isn't like
that
oh I'm just older now your hair just
loses moisture so you've got that Jill
Stein thing going on and so I have it
and god bless her she's a voted I voted
for if it's if it goes to show that you
can change
I voted me for that dumb maniac four
years ago because I was protesting
Obama's drones I've done a complete 180
on I'm gonna talk about it here but I'm
just one eighty on third-party voting
and she I think she's I don't care
people vote for I just I really don't
but I only care people attack me in hate
mobs on Twitter okay so she and I human
women act like you can't say one bad
thing about another woman you're not a
feminist that's not it means it doesn't
what it means it means if I don't want
to hire someone because they had shitty
hair but then I heard a dude with shitty
hair cuz I didn't care that's sexist but
I don't want shitty hair around me at
all man or woman you can be bombed work
it
don't give me shitty hair I want to hire
either of you go go combat go and come
back go to the driver come back to the
interview
so what I'll never convince some people
so this girl
her hair looks very greasy at the roots
that's all I'm gonna say
and she goes to me but why do I take my
mug I've literally just met her she
gives me the handshake she goes who do
you know whose whose side are you on
which I love that that's the question
you ask at a wedding as though they mean
whose side of the you know are you were
the bride's side on the groom's side but
it does sound like when this [ __ ] goes
down in the divorce whose side he you
want uh-huh
but I said oh I know this person and she
said oh and I said she has what I did I
said of a comedian she goes do you know
Alan I go Alan he like you could she
could be Allan Havey someone famous Oh
Alan [ __ ] the Broadway star I don't
know what she's something Mitch because
he's local Alan he I don't know I know
him a little bit he's a comedian and I
go no and she goes so maybe you're just
starting yep I'm just starting I'm just
brand-new cuz I don't know Alan whose
last name you won't [ __ ] tell me so
she goes do this to your hair and I'm so
sorry for the listeners at home she was
do this to your hair and then she goes I
could do herself judge your hair a
little bit I don't know it's a sleek and
smooth blow up it's not supposed to be
she's supposed to be she goes it looks
too flat on your head I'm like you look
you look like if Courtney Love died
decomposed took her head off put on the
Cryptkeeper head and then died again
that's what you look like there's
nothing I could tell her to do real
quick that would help what she looks
like
and I'm not like I wouldn't think about
her looks until she went after my hair
and I when I like it this way in she
goes do you know what dry shampoo is
that's like asking it's so insulting
when someone thinks you don't know what
a product on the market is like like
so out of it or like I came in a tool
belt or something with like a mustache
groaning like what's up guys which would
also be fine but it's like I'm I said
yes I do
my hair is not great it literally just
got it's 10 minutes washed it's not I
know it adds texture I got it but I was
like she hasn't washed her hair she was
I haven't washed my hair in a week I
just put dry shampoo and my kid looks
like that and you're at the busted beat
balls table who no one loves like
legitimately an island of misfit toys
table like not only are we single no one
has or will ever loved us it's not I'm
telling you there was me and another
person that were in a transitional
period we wouldn't have gotten a
plus-one everyone else was straight-up
left to die you know and so I don't like
to be talked to like that
at a wedding unless you're my best
friend in the world and so I just got up
and walked away and went to another
table and stood at a table full of
couples and just went in between each
one was like hey and visited with them
for a minute and then went around to
each one until until she got up and and
then I was jealous because there was a
gentleman there in a suit with a giant
statement necklace and I was like I love
him I don't know if he's gay straight
whatever he is if you just had a
beautiful like diamond necklace like I
can't even explain it like these
ornaments on the lamp were like the size
of all the things on the and I was like
oh that guy's gonna be my best friend at
this table and then he started talking
to her like real close and like intimate
I'm like what why are they best friends
how can you not tell her
your hair looks dirty sweetie like I uh
maybe he was I don't know they're in an
in-depth conversation but it brought me
to what do you do
has anyone here gotten married and
restricted the I just think on a
Saturday night a plus-one is a tough
thing to not give but now imagine to I
and I actually in that now I'm this
[ __ ] I was telling a friend who's
single and I go it's just it's like the
worst thing I could imagine I felt so
stupid because how about
not being in a relationship I go no
that's better though it is and I go yes
it is because that's your identity I'm
not in a relationship so here's how I
arrived at the wedding not in a
relationship up for fun I don't mean
meeting a man but maybe just be the life
of the party
regale people with tales of your trips
whatever but me I felt like a baby who
no one knows anything about my life and
I couldn't see my partner because I was
afraid to ask for a plus-one like I felt
like I was in a more pitiable position
and I had a big argument with a friend
it was like no and she was like it's way
worse to be single and go to a wedding
and not be able to bring someone knowing
there's no one waiting later to see you
or the next day and I was like I think
it sucks either way to just be around
couples who look at you like hmm and so
I think that but what do we do about the
plus one thing has anyone gotten married
and had to restrict the plus ones you
did what did how did you restrict them
like and how big was your wedding sixty
people in your backyard okay yes you did
invite people's boyfriends or
girlfriends but what about people's
husbands and wives
eggs okay perfect so they were friends
of yours anyway
right and so the single people did they
know each other if you see that if you
put thought into it okay so you don't
I'll just jam them in a corner or
something like that oh I love it so I
don't know if the of this for the
listeners at home the bride went to the
table to talk to them about she had a
table of the single people that couldn't
bring Plus Ones and she sat down and
facilitated conversations with them
about what they had in common like I
look at the most codependent bride like
so I haven't gotten to you guys yet I've
just been quick just got married
um I okay Marcy loves knitting John
doesn't but I think there's something
cool there maybe you could tell them
what you like about it cuz you had like
an I seemed fun table like everyone's
fun is different table yeah I don't know
what to do then I realize I did that at
my wedding I didn't have I don't think
but it was we could only fit like a
hundred people in this small venue in
Massachusetts and I we have I have 17
cousins they're all married and then
well no children were allowed but then
it's like aunts and uncles like we each
had 45 family members between us and
then we had a room for like ten friends
to come and so it was really hard and I
couldn't ask I couldn't let people just
bring a plus-one but I don't think
anyone was single I actually can't
remember because it I was selfish that
day anyway so we'll get to this article
so I guess I'll read the article now
because it goes with it so let's see if
we agree with this oh wait oh no I
didn't okay I didn't print it out my
computer is dying by the way it's just
starting to go wrong and it gets really
hot and starts shaking and then the
screen starts looking like a rainbow has
anyone had this does that mean it's
dying just get a new one right who can
deal with that
I think it's time for a new one I've had
it for four years and I feel like that's
in computer land that's old is that old
yeah it's old okay just charge it my
right ladies okay this is from I think
it was in the New York Times but I just
copied and pasted it into a Word
document and this might be boring but
gives a [ __ ] you have your food you can
with one in oh and today I was at a
coffee shop on West 3rd and the only
people populating it were women alone at
their laptops like five women or reading
or do it was just like ladies just
unashamed working reading it's great
okay when you think about some places in
the world still can't do that it's great
with one in five of us living alone why
are women being discriminated against
because of their single status oh sorry
guys I thought this was for both genders
well maybe you can really standing on a
beach and go ah I don't know what that
is geo eh where's that who Oh India I
they said Indiana I'm like no one's on
and chatting to other wedding guests
travel writer Mira tetani was having a
lovely time okay standing on a beach and
chatting to other wedding guests oh
she's waiting us until that is another
guests started talking to her I was one
of the very few singles over 30 and when
he found out I was 39 and unattached he
asked me whether I'd given up I was
stunned and said I'm 39 not dead for
Mira it was just the latest example of
single ISM the outdated attitudes women
are often subjected to if they don't
have a husband or partner she says it's
like there's a section of society that
thinks single women are bit odd if you
found someone who agrees to live with
you and spend time with you then you get
stamped with approval you've met the
requirements of life if you haven't been
validated I'm doing quotes because
that's what the article says and her
single there can be a suspicion about
you that there's something a bit wrong
with you which by the way I know I was
implying when I was talking about the
busted chick but I think sometimes there
is something wrong with people
there's absolutely
lutely something wrong with me so I
that's I relate but you know okay Mira
isn't the only one to experience this
prejudice based purely on her
relationship status in fact single ism
is a widespread form of discrimination
so much so when the Ted blog featured a
piece from expert bella de pollo in
october called the price of being single
it generated thousands of retweets and
online comments sounding just sounds
like someone out of touch wrote that
since single ism is stereotyping
stigmatizing and discrimination against
people who are single people want to
believe that marriage is a
transformational experience and that
people who get married or are in couples
will be happier healthier and just
better people that I've shown in my
research is just not true the number of
single people is growing and growing yet
single ISM isn't diminishing according
to the Office of National Statistics ons
twenty two percent of women and
twenty-eight percent of men currently
live alone in the UK the number I guess
is a UK thing the number has been
steadily rising in 1996 there were three
point nine million women living alone
now since 2012 4.1 million there will be
another by 2020 they'll be another two
million households where people live
alone o-69 those are the worst sentence
ever written since sex in the city city
celebrated single life no it did it all
they did was try to get in relationship
so it's literally every episode I'd go
to work today but I'm trying to get in a
relationship and they all ended up in
one at the end look there's nothing
wrong with it but this person never
watched an episode they're [ __ ] like
I'm gonna do a whole I seem fun and why
the second Sex in the City movie is good
and I want everyone to [ __ ]
unsubscribe if they don't think so and
I'll stop doing the podcast
who waits summon just yelled out
something amazing even the second one
where they go to Abu Dhabi I know listen
we're gonna we're gonna have a big
debate because I'm gonna give you time
to get your thoughts ready I'll get mine
and we're gonna like fight it out here
when it it's gonna I know why it's bad I
mean at least I'm not oblivious but I'll
tell you why I skip over what's bad
about it but we'll do that next month
okay or maybe not ever um all the big
things associated with marriage have
come undone says Bella women can support
themselves sure but who wants to I'm not
even [ __ ] kidding oh if my partner
made like 20 million and bought an
apartment in Tribeca I'm done I'm done
I was blatantly be like I'm living off
of you and I just want to live like I'm
on vacation like I might do an open mic
here and there but no the net okay like
in other words I make a living doing
comedy but it's [ __ ] ball breaking
work so traveling as much as I do to get
what I get it's a lot to keep up with as
I get older my hair gets more dry right
it's a lot on the body in the soul so
right now I'm playing a form of the
lottery in between gigs which is trying
to sell TV shows and doing this and
doing that and hoping that this and but
the amount of money I want is a lottery
at that point it's a lottery you can
that you can or only work so hard and
then it's either you break or you don't
or my next comedy special comes out
let's say 50 million people watch I've
become hugely famous okay that could
happen it's a lottery I do the work I
get paid for the special that's my job
the next level is lottery stuff and not
out of control with that one so if I can
win the lottery in a different way off
someone else's money I'm doing it
because I'm tired so ok they don't have
to be a romantic partner if a friend was
like I'm losing my mind here's 20
million I would be like I would not talk
them out of it I'd be like great I would
be one of those people like whoever is
keeping Richard Simmons hostage if I was
a little more conniving I would do that
to someone like else let me be the
your will and I would just take so much
money women can support themselves
advancements in reproductive science
mean they can have children alone and
that just sounds awful I mean if you
want to do it great but sons so tired
and many are buying houses too scared to
live alone in a house you know that
about me and not waiting to get married
create a real meaningful fulfilling life
that's all true yet single women still
encounter prejudice in many different
aspects how spying being one Rachel and
entrepreneur from Hampshire I really
didn't realizes the UK it's way more
sexist over there I just had an
experience with the cops and didn't tell
you on this episode I'll tell you
another time maybe
I won't cuz I need to act out physically
um I saw flat I really liked and phoned
the estate agent to book interviewing he
was quite old school and asked me to
bring my husband when I said I wasn't
married he asked me to bring my
boyfriend when I said it was saying all
he went quiet at the actual viewing I
don't feel he listened to me and was
pointing out the pretty features rather
than talking to me seriously about the
property that's been described I was
expected to cover all the awful shifts
over Christmas just because I'm single
my colleagues argued that they had
events in the diary with their partners
that were just so important and although
it was unsaid I knew they were implying
that because I was single I clearly
wouldn't have anyone to let down which
couldn't be further from the truth
you're not you're viewed as less of a
valid person yep stereotypes this and
that singles are viewed as more
self-centered and less socially mature
that's what makes me crazy I read a book
that was like really we're less mature
people who live alone or on married or
single we pay our own bills do
everything ourselves how is that
immature how how is it [ __ ] immature
so um this is two British for me it's
like annoying me so I'm gonna stop
reading it but you get the point it's a
real thing look for it it's called
single ism I'll tell you
okay so I'll tell you what happened in
the U to the K I was out and I met these
two female comics and I say female
because it's important to this story and
they were really cool and I won't out
their names and they're really nice and
we'd never met and that we went out
after one of my shows and we're like oh
let's just go
to this little I was like I can't go
anywhere allowed my voice I can't drink
my want everything my voice my voice so
we went to this little quiet place and
we're talking and you know it's 3:00
we're just talking about life or
whatever and these three guys at the bar
are watching us the whole time and we're
just waiting everyone in the tables in
relationship we're not interested anyway
and one of them comes over and just sits
down and like guys are way more weird in
London like in America they're
aggressive but they're also like this is
a terrible generalization anyone who's
been attacked would be like no but
there's something about like you think
I'll get a New York guy in the street
like the construction worker like it I
mean you're like [ __ ] you is a would
[ __ ] you you know you kind of like goes
away and but British guys like up the
ante and so they sat down and they're
like and I talked to us and we were like
no can you leave I'm very polite we're
just you know we've just matter we're
just talking and and they're like can we
buy you a drink we're like no because
you don't want to know the drink like no
because then that means you think you're
gonna be able to sit with us and it's
gonna be rude of us to accept a drink
it's like we're all fine we're all fine
and so then they keep coming back and
bothering us and it got to the point
where one girls like look you're being
rude and you guys are really drunk and
we're actually having a serious
conversation and he was like oh and he's
like didn't and so we went up I went up
to the bar to get us around and the
girls and the bartender is making them
and I was trying to explain like water
with lemon which wasn't going well
because I was like not fizzy water but
and so then the guy at the bar was like
one of the boys was like I'll buy it for
you and I was like no I'm not drinking
this because I don't have any money it's
my throat I don't get into it and so
then he's like why can't we come back to
the table he's trying to like ask me on
his own I go because we're talking about
important things like literally when
girls get together it's never a small
talk I go she's telling me about one of
her friends of his cancer and this guy
I'm not kidding picture and played by
like Adrien Brody but with long hair and
it's wild and he's sitting alone slumped
over the bar he's not with the three
young dudes and he he's probably like 40
or something but he's scary looking and
he he's hunched over the bar
here's me say we're talking about like
important things he goes what you got to
talk about that so important my
girlfriend died in the bath
and I was like what and then he then he
went back and slumped over the bar and I
was like and so I said to the but -
bartender ladies I said I'm kind of
scared of these guys can you like are
there bouncers here that can like tell
them to leave us alone
and they were like literally just didn't
answer to say no and so then the
bartender the bartender guy was like
making the drinks and these boys
wouldn't leave us alone and I went over
the girls I'm like this is never gonna
[ __ ] end because they don't care and
they're like let's just [ __ ] leave
and so we got up and left
and um I was like I was like the guy was
still screaming she'd died in the bath
women don't have any more problems and
men knew and I was like in that scenario
she's the one dead in the bath is the
one with the problem I don't know if you
so also people die in bathtubs I don't
know why maybe she killed herself I
don't know what it was but if she did
that's means she was severely sick and
again I don't see how whatever okay so
we leave we go across the street to like
a little pizzeria kind of place they're
like okay well just get like coffee and
talk and so we tell the guys behind the
counter there are men that might follow
us in here we don't know them they are
very drunk don't let them stay and we
sit and all of a sudden here come the
boys and they come in and then we go
that's them they don't do anything about
it and they come to our table why don't
you want to hang out with us and there
now they're getting grabby and pokey and
we're like can you call the cops can you
call the cops and and so we were trying
to just threaten them we didn't really
think the cops come and the boys like oh
don't call the cops and they scurried
away and like went to a table and then
I'm not kidding here comes the guy
running and my girlfriend dawn in the
back he ran in he went right in my face
it was screaming it and I almost heard a
cry it was shaking and then finally the
pizza place people called the cops
the cops come and they drag the women
out they come to our table and they're
like is that them they're like yup and
they're like I'm more like what the [ __ ]
and they're like come on come on outside
and they're screaming and I go I'm not
going you ought to physically drag me so
he takes my arm
physically drags me and I just kind of
go limp and I just London dragged me and
I'm like and I go outside and I go
excuse me these men have been harassing
us on and it goes no calm down you're
hysterical I go no I'm not
I'm being [ __ ] harassed meanwhile I'm
not joking as he's calling me hysterical
the guy with the girlfriend down in the
bath is still on the street he's more
circling he's losing his [ __ ] I go that
guy's hysterical he goes you got him
that way I go no I didn't and I go how
would that how come I go have you ever
been sexually harassed sir he goes your
your personal history with sexual
harassment has nothing to do with this I
go oh I [ __ ] thing it is everything
to do with this because that's why I'm
so [ __ ] angry right now because I
can't go out [ __ ] once women can't do
[ __ ] it's like it's [ __ ] Saudi Arabia
everywhere like we can't go out without
getting bothered all the time and he's
like calm down that's not true you're
exaggerating I'm sure they've been some
nights you went out where people weren't
harassing you I go you're being a dick
and he was like and he goes I go
women like oh this [ __ ] leads to rape
and he goes oh come on I go have you
been raped he goes yes I have I go [ __ ]
you you have it and I'm like I'm talking
to a policeman and I'm abroad and maybe
not I am abroad but I'm also abroad I'm
in the UK and perhaps I shouldn't get my
passport taken away or arrested but he
doesn't seem to care that I'm saying
[ __ ] you I don't believe you've been
raped you're a dick and so I go and he
goes what do you want me to do tonight I
go I want you to just tell those guys to
leave I go but now I'm in such a bad
mood and when I hang out with my friends
anyway
and I go can I just leave or like do I
have to go to jail or something and he
goes you can go and I go I'm getting out
of here and I just walked home and that
was it and I I told the girls I was like
I'm gonna go I didn't realize we could
just walk away from cops here and they
were like ah right bye and then they
stayed and argued with him for an hour
they emailed me later and they're like
we finally got him to admit that maybe
the guys were harassing us and then like
they all left peacefully and I was like
what is good like not only is that white
privilege I guess but it's also I guess
a bizarre world of cops that don't exist
here like I got to I didn't
I didn't know you could say I don't care
that you got raped or I don't believe
you you're being a dick I don't think I
could say that to a cop here and have it
go so well and just have him go like get
out of here you rascal but so on one
hand I appreciate that they didn't do
[ __ ] about I mean the guys in the sense
of they didn't do [ __ ] about me I mean I
did the guys didn't do anything to them
they were just being drunk guys I was
the one that was like [ __ ] you your
dicks so but um well it's just like the
lyrics to that whose song I guess I just
realized I woke up in a SOHO doorway the
policeman knew my name he said you'll
get your sleep at home tonight if you
can get up and walk away okay so um I
don't like that story because I feel
like it makes me seem crazy which I
think the reason it does because I was
acting crazy today I went to get my
watch fixed great it's already amazing
an amazing night of tales and I went in
and another guy at the store that wasn't
the guy fixing my watch goes you have a
really cool voice and I go oh thanks and
it was really raspy this morning because
the [ __ ] acid reflux it's not getting
better and I said thanks and he goes
really do you know that and I go oh no I
know about my voice yeah and he goes
it's so different I go yeah it's damaged
from acid in my esophagus it's coming up
backwards for five years undetected so
yeah it's um I don't I hate my voice and
he goes it's really cool I go yeah no he
goes dude you voiceover I go nope
because actually I stopped getting
voiceover work when my voice started
getting bad years ago because I don't
have any range I go I really don't talk
about it and he said I'm well you should
do something with your voice I cook my
guys speak for a living that's what yeah
my comedian and I'm it hinders what I do
actually this voice cuz it's not it's
medical and I don't want to talk about
any more but I kept saying more [ __ ]
just to see will this shut him the [ __ ]
up and it didn't and so he was like how
would you play flappers in Burbank not
that there's anything wrong with it but
it is a comedy club if you don't know
that I believe they don't pay I don't
mean to say in this Landers way but if
they do pay it's like you know it's your
gas money or you don't I mean maybe it's
50 bucks I don't even know if it's that
but um what people don't know who don't
do comedy is you
don't make a living doing it in LA
that's never the goal you live in LA
because you're working and wait you're
auditioning for sitcoms or whatever
you're doing on the side and then you
run your sets of improv at them other
places that little alternative rooms to
get your material going to be part of
your community to get seen everything
seen as a showcase you won't get paid
but people will see you and it actually
is true where you make your money
obviously it's going on tour and so I go
no I don't really do it because I'm
sorry I'm like no no it's a choice I go
I I toured the world and he goes well
maybe he didn't say maybe you and have
to goes maybe if you got in there you
could take a break from that sometimes
no no I can't unless I want to make
fifty dollars a year I cannot do that
but thank you for the suggestion
nobody should [ __ ] first of all no
one should talk to comedians never talk
to comedians you're never right not you
guys is on its own audience listening at
home you're never right don't stop okay
that's how I say this is we have some
icing fun updates and I don't know see I
barely remember stuff so maybe you guys
will this this is a follow up to a guy
do you remember there was a listener
email a few months ago this guy I don't
remember let's just read the email hi
Jen you can read my name I heard and
then I heard you read an inspiring
follow-up email and I thought I'd share
I heard you read and in spa okay many
months a many months ago I emailed you
this is from Robin I know if it's a man
or woman many months ago I emailed you
looking for guidance as I was dating a
guy I'd spent many years off and on with
who is bad for me I was also in love
with a friend I sent the email forgot
about it
I think tamesha me then after a trip
away with my friends at Easter this year
I was driving home alone sad my
boyfriend didn't attend yet again and
also a little lovestruck with a man I'd
met there I was determined when I got
home it was over I was emotional then
your podcast came on the episode is nice
bod bad couch and I had to pull over
when you read my letter I was sobbing
that week I left him and I also happen
to have booked seats for my girlfriends
and I at your show I had told my
girlfriends that week going to your show
is a very special experience for me and
they were keen to find out why exactly
this must be an Australian because I
think it was April yeah anyway you were
right about the friend also I don't know
what I said it sounds great we have we
have stayed loving friends I am single
and enjoying the ups and downs of that
experience but importantly I have my
confidence building and I feel inner
peace and happiness within myself I
honestly do I hope all your listeners
who feel trapped in love with someone
they shouldn't be with get the courage
from my story to walk out and move on
like the pink skirt girl Rob I don't
remember that one
but if any I hope you're all inspired by
that story oh this is a story about I
got a bad review in England but from the
Guardian newspaper I didn't read it but
someone told me who did read it said Jen
I read The Guardian review of your show
the author mentions 9/11 in the very
first line and then again later
I'd call that a win love your podcast
okay oh and I'm flying for my first time
on 9/11 since 9/11 from JFK to LAX this
year fun oh you don't know how badly I
want something to happen so I can take a
break no no not to die not to die but
just like I know like a mini threat that
we get to land early or something and
then I'm like oh I'm so upset I need
time off
do you think they're releasing Sully on
September 9th because of the we're in
the plane kind of New York moon and
September 11th week because they could
have released it Labor Day that's some
people go to movies what do you think
yes did someone just say whoa oh no
would you say what or whoa
oh I thought you were like whoa like I
just blew your mind okay this is about
me and I seem fun person at my show I'm
sitting at home after your book to her
show in Vancouver wanted to share a
little story from today loved your show
I was really excited for the show as
lately I've been especially enjoying
your podcast I always think it's great
but the two most recent just really hit
me especially the one called by the time
I get dot when you talk about the
wonderful idealized version you have in
your head of the podcast listeners it
was such a lovely sentiment and it left
me just grinning away while I walked
around town anyways I showed up at the
Rio that's venue I performed pretty
early as I work close by and I figured
I'd just go straight there I got in soon
after the doors opened and I thought
what the hell and went for a front row
seat I was on my own there's a theme
here tonight and I so I just grabbed the
aisle seat in the main center Bank of
seats about a half hour afterwards I
noticed a large chatty group of women
looking to find seats they all just
seemed very tall and blond and I
immediately was put in the mind of the
fact the haters girl I then thought that
that maybe this was a bit too unkind of
me until they asked if I'd be willing to
move from my seat to accommodate their
late large group and not just to shift
one seat to the side they suggested I
could go to the second row or to the
bank of seats to the far left across the
aisle if I quote still want to be in the
front row I politely declined and they
assured me that it was no problem
outside the theater after the show I
overheard a woman walking next to me
tell her friend there was puke in the
women's bathroom at a Jen Kirkman show
probably that horrible group of drunk
women I realized she was talking about
the same group and then confirmed that
was the case it turned out that these
two that had been sitting behind me and
then they saw me oh these two icing
funders had been sitting behind me and
they saw them asked me to move and they
let me know they were rooting for me to
deny their request and stay put I don't
for sure if they were I assume funders
but I certainly got that vibe from them
and I was reminded of your sentiment
from the podcast and those drunk girls I
did kick out of the show too so thank
you wait what's this oh but this one's
about to prep depression oh wait here
this is but let's see one about perfume
and then depression and then really
quick with I want each of you not each
of you but a cup of you that are willing
to give advice to this girl but where to
meet people because I don't know
especially if you have it's worked for
you if you're in a relationship you met
someone different than like online
because this person said she tried all
the online dating and it's not working
but she'd see here's the thing she said
she goes I usually message them first
and don't hear back and she goes and I
don't even like that stuff anyway and
I'm like mmm I can just in your emails
long they sound long don't they I don't
normally like this definis and then I've
never met anyone like who you know like
I just have a feeling so anyway I'm
running from Toronto where I work as a
shoemaker I'm also an artist I listen to
I seem fun as I work it seems like
you're someone who takes pleasure and
pride in cultivating personal style and
clothing and home decor
I'm curious at this attention to
aesthetic detail extends to selecting
perfumes for body or home a [ __ ]
course it does I have a different
scented candle in every room with
different scents and it's like madness
and so it's my favorite thing and I
won't tell you the name of the candles
because I don't want people to
rich-bitch me but they're amazing and
and I like things that smell like
tobacco and like woodsy and plum and
then some lemon like all different
things vanilla I love it what kind of
perfume do you wear I wear I've been
wearing it my college boyfriend wore it
and I don't know why it was like an
essential oil called Egyptian Musk and I
loved how it smelled on him and I don't
think he wears anymore because he used
to be like hey I've got feather in here
and I'm wearing bell-bottoms it's 1996
and I'm oh I loved it and so I was like
I'm gonna take that as my signature
scent because I know we're gonna break
up and or you'll stop wearing it so I
wear and I worn that for 20 years and
again at the farmers market here in LA
called essence of nature thanks that's
an
brant that's named in the story and then
I have Chanel number five it's a classic
and I buy it once every two years at
some Airport or something
okay but then I'm always afraid to wear
because member of Marilyn Monroe that
was her campaign when I only wear to bed
Chanel number five meaning she sleeps
naked but she was found naked in bed and
so every time I wear Chanel number five
and I smell it on me in bed am i coming
to dye my sleep and so awesome I
probably won't die my sleeve because I
didn't take a million pills nor are the
Kennedys trying to get me so though I
told you that that's a big thing my
mother sat me down with when I was a kid
Jennifer the Kennedys killed Marilyn
that's all you have to know she knew too
much Bobby would tell her about the mom
I don't know why they came in and they
put like a pendant in him but and they
made it look like an overdose I mean
that could be true she didn't leave a
suicide note so it's probably just an OD
but they called it suicide because I
think that was more is it that that was
more socially acceptable back then
suicide was more acceptable than OD'ing
because then you would have to admit oh
she did drugs a lot instead of oh just
that one time I guess we had to go okay
this is a story about doctors I don't
care right now we'll do it another time
Oh may I mention to all the listeners
listening I mean not you guys here I'm
gonna be in Buffalo New York at the
helium comedy club I think they think
I'm crazy because a lot of people online
we're trying to get the show canceled
because I tweeted a joke that I guess I
wasn't supposed to tweet I don't know if
you knew this I had a giant scandal on
Twitter based on a joke I tweeted that
went like this and this is all the joke
said I like all caps that Hillary
Clinton's killed a bunch of people that
was it I got thousands of people
attacking me they put it on reddit I did
I blocked 600 people and I now no longer
run my own Twitter I won't even look at
it because it's it literally became a
hain't mob and then on these articles
were written about it and people were
like die [ __ ] you you [ __ ] and then they
were like basically what it was was I
don't can't be like Hillary or don't but
the thing of like every day someone dies
and they're like Hillary had him killed
like I was talking about all those
people
they say she has killed like he used to
work at the census now he's dead you
know and it's like or Vince Foster is
kind of like an old 90s joke about
everything old is new again like though
everything they say is like she killed
people I wasn't talking about Benghazi
or what I wasn't talking about actual
people that may have died by the way she
was never the [ __ ] president like she
didn't order the deaths of any well
again I can't get into it but but
everyone in any administration secretary
state president yeah you're all under
the umbrella of the people who make
decisions people die I'm sorry to tell
everyone every president has blood on
his pants every Secretary of State does
I don't know what to say
so um but that was the joke was not
about those rumors but and so all these
people attacked it was he's young they
call themselves I can't even say what
they call themselves because they like
they get mad when old people say it so
they go there like say comes those
social justice warriors or they don't or
they don't like being called that I
don't really know what the whole thing
is but I've had people turn on me big
fans of mine someone started an account
the other day called Julie delete jen
kirkman and it said what if hillary
killed her I actually got it suspended
I've never been able to get an account
suspended but there was an actual death
thrown on it so a Twitter and that will
stop the person - real life from
shooting me I'm sure so um anyway so
they were tweeting the helium comedy
club in Buffalo like you're gonna
support someone who makes jokes about
dead people of color and so this girl
like this hysterical teenager wrote me
Oh real funny joke about how Hillary has
dead dead babies I mean all the dead
babies that died under Hillary would
love to be at your shows and laugh and I
go so I was just [ __ ] with her
because that's a crazy teenage thing to
say to a grown woman about politics
right I don't care if you don't like
Hillary you would not say that right can
we all agree i retweeted it in wrote I
don't want a bunch of dead Afghanistan
babies at my shows that's weird or
something like that
oh my god and then I deleted it cuz now
cuz I was ashamed but I'm like I'm just
bringing more on myself and then with
these kids they think you delete it cuz
you're scared of them and I was just
like I don't want anymore [ __ ] and they
took pictures of it change on later that
and she was doing this and so it went a
whole thing and so the helium comedy
club I think is like what the [ __ ] they
don't want to be involved so the people
at home please tweet at the helium
comedy club if you're coming just find
their address on Twitter they're one of
my favorite clubs in the country and
just say I'm coming to see Jen Kirkman
and I'm so excited and at me and at them
please do it for me and if you are
coming but haven't got your tickets yet
just say I'm gonna get the tickets at
the door just let them know people are
coming and that date is September
September o 8th through 10th so they'll
be five shows and then Portland Oregon
I'm there the 15th 16th and 17th there's
alive I seem fun taping on Thursday the
15th and then Labor Day weekend
Scottsdale Arizona stand up Scottsdale
September 1st through 3rd I think it's a
great thing if you have tickets to any
of these not you guys to tweet the clubs
I am coming to see Jen Kirkman thanks
for booking her I'm so excited
not that you need to thank them like my
agent makes them it's not a big deal but
I want them to feel the love because
they've been getting so much abuse from
the kids from the kids online and so
yeah so I don't that's why if you ever
tweet at me it's I don't see it anymore
so I apologize for that I don't know
when I'm gonna be back because I can't
take it so oh the other jokes it would
be up so what they did and then they go
back through history of tweets so two
years ago when I was upset it was August
2015 I guess we must have been on
remember now we must have been talking
about going to war with Iran maybe or
maybe it was when Obama was negotiating
or something and people we should go to
war instead so I wrote as an anti-war
joke and you can tell when I write any
comedian or any person write something
in all lowercase like it's I think that
implies like sarcasm and Selena's are
like this is a character I'm doing not
me I wrote I think we should go to war
in Iran we always go to Iraq try
something new fun and they go look at J
rah look what she wrote they literally
put it on reddit thousands of people
were passing it around I kept refreshing
my feet and I was like oh my god it was
it wouldn't
stop and they I said it was satire or
irony or whatever the [ __ ] it is and
they go but the victims of the jokes are
the dead people I go no the victims of
the Joe little victims the joke is on
the power structure that we just invade
everywhere and how many times we've and
how flip we are to everything that's the
joke it's a I'm not saying I'm anything
like George Carlin but it's in that
spirit right of that kind of comedy
telling I'm in light years away from it
but it's and they're like she's trying
to be edgy and she's not I'm like no I'm
not trying to be edgy and they they
literally I'm sorry that there's there's
young people here at listening your
generation maybe not you you don't
understand [ __ ] humor and it's
scaring me it's what I remember on 9/11
in New York yes organically have a story
about it everyone was like is irony dead
is humor dead and a week later everyone
was like [ __ ] no and everyone's at the
comedy clubs and we were laughing we
were laughing about 9/11 when people had
died we could still smell the bodies and
we're laughing about it
don't you [ __ ] twenty year olds tell
me when to [ __ ] make jokes you stupid
oh I hope the whole I hope Hillary's
president and that she is a crazy war
monger and she blows up the world
because you don't deserve to grow up
I [ __ ] hate them I [ __ ] hate them
I could bring Trump in we really know
he's gonna do it bring in it let him be
we've all lived a good life right let
these [ __ ] [ __ ] their pants when he is
president and guess what we'll do well
make fun of them sorry I got so mad I
was gonna gonna read an email but I
guess I won't I'm selling up something's
a merchandise after the show I have
copies in my book for 20 bucks there's
four dollars cheaper than you can get at
the bookstore if you want to buy it and
I have I seen fun months and posters but
right now before we go I am going to ask
people does anyone here feel like they
have a really good idea of where a girl
can meet a guy who doesn't like online
dating and doesn't drink a lot and if
you can if you have examples of how this
worked for you great if it's just an
idea that's fine too I will come around
with my microphone so that you can talk
directly to your fellow I seem fun or
please do it for them anyone raise your
hand if you have any advice now one
person
how about like bad advice even if it if
it's just like you know something must
have come into your head like something
popped in here anyway no that's dumb
this is just even that yes where where
are you okay what's your name oh you're
a comic okay would you solve a name
hijack you fabulous
okay tell everyone jackie fabulous calm
all the social medias jackie fabulous a
girlfriend of mine did a recycle your ex
party and and she did it a few years ago
and then it became a regular thing and
now she's trying to really like do it on
a remanent basis and you just have to be
okay with yeah and I've never done it
because personally any ex that I have I
wouldn't want to refer him but I wanna I
don't wanna I don't want to close the
door if he's worthy of dating one of my
friends
if he's a [ __ ] up then he can go to this
party to have a great time your ex party
that's funny too if he's a [ __ ] yeah
give him to my friend anyone else have
any ideas yes this is the woman who had
the 60 person wedding it was very kind
to her guests at the singles table yeah
hi I member has been at a vegan dinner
party that was weekly in LA every
Tuesday night and people would just
bring wine and it was like a bunch of
interesting people talking around the
table and how did you meet these fellow
vegans or were they not vegans but they
desert a vegan dinner just like a vegan
chef that was like a four-course amazing
meal and then like not vegans and
non-vegans what kind of it was it at
this venue called HM one57 in Lincoln
Heights and so how'd you find out about
it my friend's friend was the chef the
dinners no longer happened there but I
bet there's other similar stuff that
happens and then also they still have
other events there and it's like a bunch
of like adults who like go to this party
it's not like annoying well this person
is 22 and doesn't live in LA so that's a
great idea for no but I think that's
great like something like that see these
are ideas I think are good anyone else
before we end this person's gonna
not ever get laid if you don't help them
what do you think I thought a bookstore
is that crazy it's dumb right okay what
about like what about a cute guy that
works in the coffee shop this one girls
nodding why is that a bad idea cuz and
you have to like talk to do i watch too
many Hallmark Christmas movies
no there isn't that's all they're
starting so [ __ ] soon I can't [ __ ]
wait I hung out with some actress friend
with her moment a friend of a friend and
they've all been like oh yeah we get
straight-up offers to be in them in my
quad and they're like successful and
well-known further things so they're
like well I can't do that I'm like oh my
god it's my dream anyway well I'm sorry
to the person out there you know my
advice take a year off and then they'll
come flocking and if they don't well go
to the vegan dinner alright well this
has been a pleasure sorry I got some mad
at that you know I feel so free and
comfortable with you guys and then
that's gonna be released into the world
and it's gonna start the whole thing up
again so don't like tweet about it if
anyone's out there let's just let it be
underground I should take that out if me
going I hope Hillary blows up the
world's like that's pretty blatant no I
know I just I want to get killed but you
know I probably will alright anyway have
a great week I'll see you outside be one
of my sink bye Owen till next week got
fun Thank You Dax thank you Mike thank
everyone at their brother
you